er ist ministerpräsident jetzt kein
schüler oder lasche den die meisten
deutschen kennen er regiert halt
sachsen-anhalt reiner haseloff bisher
nicht so besonders wichtig für den rest
deutschlands da in seinem fernsehsessel
aber in dieser woche bei erst er
verhindert hat dass wir alle noch mehr
rundfunkgebühr zahlen müssen noch mehr
als 8 milliarden euro im jahr
er hat das gesetz gestoppt ausgeknipst
weg gesetzt daraufhin plötzlich riesen
empörung ein schaden für die demokratie
sollte das seinen angriff auf den
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk dieser
mann er habe das geschäft der afd
betrieben heißt es nein hat er nicht
mitten in der korona krise muss es doch
das erste sein ganz genau zu fragen ob
der öffentlich rechtliche rundfunk
wirklich mehr als 8 milliarden euro im
jahr braucht es ist richtig dann auch
mit dem zweiten auge noch mal ganz genau
auf die kosten zu schauen
kritik an der ard ist nicht afd